[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
Fourier transform and some of its neat
properties that make it useful for
solving partial differential equations
and for function approximation and now
I'm gonna tell you about two of my
absolute favorite properties the first
one is really really simple and very
very important and I'll let you kind of
work through and convince yourself that
this is true which is that the Fourier
transform is a linear operator so if I
take the Fourier transform of some alpha
f of X plus some beta G of X this is
going to equal alpha times the Fourier
transform of f plus beta times the
Fourier transform of G for all functions
F and G and for all real numbers or
complex numbers alpha and beta okay so
that's the definition the the property
that needs to be satisfied for this
Fourier transform operator to be a
linear operator is that if I add two
functions if I take the Fourier
transform of F plus G it should just be
the Fourier transform of F plus the
Fourier transform of G even if I scale
them by some constant alpha and beta
okay so I'll let you work through this
you can literally take this expression
plug it in here and it's very simple I
mean these these if you had alpha F plus
beta G here you could just split that up
into two integrals you could pop the
Alpha and the beta out and you'd recover
this property that that's simply okay so
that's easy the next thing I'm going to
tell you about is something called
parseval's theorem and I don't think
this is the same Parsifal from King
Arthur's knights of the round table they
say I don't think so par Seville's
theorem but this is an extremely
extremely useful theorem that allows us
to use the Fourier transform for matrix
for function approximation okay so I'm
just going to write it out and then I'm
going to talk you through what this
means so what this tells you is that the
integral from minus infinity to infinity
of the absolute value of the Fourier
transform of F
squared D Omega is equal to two pi times
the integral from minus infinity to
infinity of the absolute value of f of x
squared DX
okay now this might seem rather simple
or rather dull but this is actually
quite a profound statement and it's
going to allow us to approximate these
functions f what this says is that this
is kind of a representation of how much
energy there is in this function f this
is kind of like the norm of f okay how
big how much energy in or you know
yeah area squared under the curve of F
there is and that's similarly how much
energy or area squared under the curve
of the Fourier transform there is and
what this parseval's theorem says is
that these two integrals are equal up to
a constant of two pi okay so kind of the
energy in F is directly proportional to
how much energy is in its Fourier
transform
okay I'm using the word energy to
represent this norm here okay and that's
extremely extremely useful because what
that means is that if there are some
really really small Fourier coefficients
if I Fourier transform f of X and there
are some really really small Fourier
coefficients and I just ignore them i
zero them out this integral won't change
much and the question is if I zero out
those small Fourier coefficients that
are really really negligible maybe it
changes f of X a lot maybe it has a big
impact on my approximation of F what
this theorem says is that if there are
48 coefficients that are negligibly
small and I remove them I set them equal
to zero I truncate my Fourier series or
Fourier transform and remove those
almost zero Fourier coefficients because
this integral doesn't change much it
tells me that I'm still capturing most
of my function f of X so if I truncate
my small Fourier coefficients I
negligibly degrade my approximation of
my function f of X that's a soon
for useful property we're going to use
that all the time when we write these
Fourier transforms and we use these to
approximate functions is the fact that
if there are small Fourier coefficients
I can ignore them and I'll still do a
pretty good job of approximating my
function f of X super useful this is
related to the fact that the Fourier
transform is a unitary operator which
means essentially it preserves kind of
distances between functions if I had two
functions F and G in x coordinates and I
Fourier transform them they're gonna
have the same inner product in Fourier
transform coordinates okay that's
another kind of subtle property of
impossibles theorem okay super useful
really really important for function
approximation if we want to ignore small
fourier coefficients okay thank you